DANE WHITMAN
Why didn't you guys help fight Thanos?
Or any war or all the other
terrible things throughout history?
SERSI
We were instructed not to interfere
in any human conflicts
unless Deviants were involved.
DANE WHITMAN
By who?
KEVIN FEIGE
The Eternals explores the very creation
of the Marvel universe itself.
NATE MOORE
The film also deals very much with
the aftermath of Avengers 4
and the state the world is in.
GEMMA CHAN
Five of the Eternals are
more of the thinkers,
and the other five
are the stronger fighters.
KEVIN FEIGE
Eternals are these remarkably
superpowered characters,
but also a
dysfunctional family unit.
SPRITE
So this is what the end of the world
looks like.
At least we have front row seats.
PHASTOS
You know what's never saved the planet?
Your sarcasm.
KEVIN FEIGE
The person to bring that together
was Academy Award
winner Chloé Zhao.
CHLOÉ ZHAO
We go on these emotional journeys
with these Eternals to
figure out who they are
and what it means to be human.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Her vision is so clear.
SALMA HAYEK
It's not the typical place,
it's not the typical shots,
it's not the typical cast.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Everybody looks different,
everybody sounds different.
ANGELINA JOLIE
A lot of people are gonna see
themselves as superheroes
for the first time.
GEMMA CHAN
It really is an epic, global film.
The scope and
the scale of it is huge.
SALMA HAYEK
It's so exciting to be a part
of something
that really feels new.
KEVIN FEIGE
The impact that Eternals will have
on the MCU will be
nothing less than redefining
the cinematic universe entirely.